yep yep yep okay so and it's and it's
understandable I think that they don't
want to have to they only have so much
money to invest and they don't want to
have to invest it necessarily everywhere
if there are other uh means of uh for
people to con to connect available so if
there's Wireless available or if there's
Internet available you know why invest
in putting in a a phone line that maybe
isn't necessary
um and that does seem like a legitimate
um purpose to me at least the concern
that that I had listening to the
testimony and that I that I still have
is how do you make sure that
um
that the people that
you know that people that that you know
um that you're not leaving anybody
behind
um and
um you know and and then the process and
making sure that there is a clear
process of uh explaining to people that
they potentially are going to lose their
phone service that they have to uh find
Alternatives
um that that type of stuff
um and
um you know so what what I tried to do
was
there has been some work done on this in
in Maine
and I took a look at that and what I
tried to do in this in this you know
potential Amendment and I'll just say
right off the bat that um there's no
pride of authorship here I just put this
together as a way to kind of get things
going but was trying to first of all
Define
okay so how what what specific criteria
are we going to use to determine you
know whether
um
potentially a phone company could
petition to loot to be relieved of the
um carrier of Last Resort so you know
and you know what map is going to be
used and and kind of what are the
criteria
there is a map that's being developed by
the New Hampshire Department of Business
and economic Affairs I understand that
they've asked for the data uh yesterday
they're supposed to publish it at the
end of the month and just you know I
thought it would make sense in the
legislation to say okay you got to use
we're going to use this map as the basis
for determining whether whether a
petition can be filed and then I stuck
with the the language that's in the bill
right now the 95 percent of households
that have access to
um
uh um
mobile or or Internet and 97 percent
yeah yeah the 95 and the 97 I left that
in there and then
um I also left in the language about you
know
um
uh you know areas where there's Federal
funding available to upgrade the um the
internet service and then basically just
put in some criteria some some steps in
terms of notification how people have to
be notified
um essentially it's
the the people have to be notified
um
in their in their bill that this is
happening
there needs to be a public hearing
um and then the doe has to make a final
decision within a certain period of time
um so that's really what this amendment
is doing
um it still it doesn't get at the issue
that I'm still struggling with is okay
what happens about what happens in that
situation where there's that you know
and I you know that that that one person
in a valley somewhere that you know has
a phone line but doesn't have access to
Internet or mobile I mean what happens
to that person I I don't know how you
address that one
so that's
hopefully that helps but that's kind of
the money's for the federal monies that
went to each County but they each got a
check by population so we had gotten
like 3.3 million up in kowas County so
the first investment we took with any of
that money was to do the Broadband map
we just got it back a week ago up north
there's none of none of my with the
Lancaster District thing on it so I'm
still trying to find out there's another
one coming out I don't know what the
other one is is this one or what because
I know there's a couple of maps that
have been being done right now so that
was the big investment was to make sure
you know what was the Broadband studies
so we had
we had invested a couple hundred
thousand a couple hundred thousand and
put up there so
um
it's a work in progress
if you go you know I went to the um the
Department of Business and economic
Affairs website and
um they they have a they they have a
page where they're talking about you
know the mapping that's being done
um and that's from what I understand and
there may be people here that can
comment on that but from what I
understand that's supposed to be the
definitive map
uh replacing all the other Maps but I I
Sarah Davis with Consolidated
Communications
as I understand it the Bea went out to
bid for somebody to perform mapping the
University of New Hampshire won that bid
and Carol Miller is sort of leading that
and all of the providers in the state
are providing data as of yesterday we
had to file data with the FCC as of
yesterday so it might take us a day or
two to get it over to her but within the
next few days she'll be getting that and
and they're using that to put together a
Statewide map as we understand it the
state of New Hampshire was not keen on
the idea of accepting the FCC map they
want to produce their own and so that's
that's sort of the New Hampshire map if
you will although based largely on the
same data because providers are already
questions
um does that include does that include
broadband and wireless access as well or
is it just landline access
um I I know for sure it includes
Broadband access I'm not sure and I I
wouldn't want to guess on exactly how
they're mapping wireless wireless is
always a bit tricky there are Wireless
Maps available but I'm just not positive
what they're doing with respect to that
probably a better question for the
agency
um
quick question for you the um I know a
lot of cable companies internet
companies they provide both internet and
phone together
um do you find that you uh do you is
that one some of the things you offer to
most towns or all your pro to all the
tones you provide for both internet and
phone yeah so can Consolidated is a
traditional
um eye lack of traditional phone company
so we operate a copper network with with
voice options we also have been
expanding at this point to over 274 000
residents in New Hampshire on a fiber
Network because fiber is the future sort
of as he outlined earlier the copper
Network's going away switch components
are difficult to obtain all of those
things so we build out with fiber with
that service we provide both the
internet connection and then a voice
over Internet Protocol of VoIP platform
which delivers voice
foreign
offering on the Broadband is is less
expensive than the traditional copper
offerings because it can be delivered in
yeah this isn't a question specifically
for you but I just want to say that I'm
really concerned about the accuracy of
mapping cellular coverage I live in an
area where I can I barely get one bar
and I'm on a west facing slope I can see
Killington from my house and I'm lucky
to get one bar sure I go half a mile
from my house on a road that's in a
little Hollow it's a dead zone and also
just the the coverage can change from
from day to day or season to season so
there might be a place that has coverage
in the winter but not in the summer
so yeah I just get really concerned
about
if someone is going to be in a place
where we're talking about no wire line
access
and we say well you know you do have one
bar of cell coverage today that doesn't
mean that they're going to have coverage
yeah well two things
um certainly the the the wire line is
you know to the extent maybe a wireless
service isn't working but a wire line is
then that can connect via home Wi-Fi so
that is sort of a a secondary
um I personally can't get cell phone I
live in Maine I can't get cell phone
coverage at my house but I like the
carrier I'm with and so I I rely on my
internet to some extent
um that's that's sort of one Fail-Safe
but the the other thing is there's
always the ability of satellite phones
there's a lot of different others and
when we worked this bill in Maine which
was in 2012 that you know the the goal
was to find a balance between you know
making sure that people were largely
covered and that there would be some
contingent and there was this
availability of of sort of Alternatives
a satellite phone works
um the kangamangus highway is the only
place I've ever been that I've seen that
one doesn't work the the thing about
satellite though is that um again that's
weather dependent right you know think
about people who have satellite dishes
and it's snowing and you know they they
don't really have great service
um I think you're you might be confusing
um sort of a like HughesNet type
satellite delivered internet service
versus like a true satellite phone that
people use when they go deep into the
woods and other things my understanding
is the technology that deploys that is
actually very reliable like I said
um there you you can get lost in the
absolute middle of nowhere with Mount
Washington in the way but that is is
very rare
can you can you talk about
um
you know where realistically
you I know you're only one carrier but
where realistically you would be you
know petitioning for a relief of this
this obligation and
yeah sure so so there's two can two two
things outlined in the bill
um with respect to that so first is that
there is sufficient competition right
utility Monopoly utility regulation is
under a theory that you're a monopoly
right you are the only electric provider
and therefore we need to check your
rates check all these things because
there isn't a market dealing with that
so the first the first aspect of it is
there is a market there are cable
competitors that we're going
head-to-head with that don't have this
additional burden on them that frankly
is unfunded by us and so it it's really
to allow us to compete to me that's
Nashua that's Manchester that's Concord
I mean the numbers have to be pulled and
verified but but those are the type of
places that we're talking with respect
to that the second area is where
um very clearly the state has chosen to
invest in another provider to provide
service to the entire town so this State
gave New Hampshire Electric Co-op 50
million dollars to build out to all of
Plymouth Plymouth already has a cable
provider for 95 plus percent of it now
they're going to have a fiber provider
that the state is funding fully funding
to build over it it probably doesn't
make sense for Consolidated to come in
and invest and be a third provider there
that's not a good use of our money
probably we're probably better served to
upgrade our Network in other areas where
they could use it more so those are the
two two ideas one is very clearly there
is a lot of competition the second is
the state very state or Municipal but
municipalities don't have a lot of this
money to do this have clearly invested
in somebody else to cover the entirety
of that area so those those are the two
concepts so you know one is the very the
Manchester's conquerors the other is is
areas such as Plymouth is sort of the
big one
um
oh sorry
um so did you did I hear you say that
you worked on a similar Bill the the
main bill yeah I I actually drafted and
negotiated at the time this bill in
Maine okay so I have some specific
questions about about this this bill and
I just want to make sure I mean there's
30 days 30 days 30 days 60 days 14 days
180 days six months have you have you or
Chris not not um not I beg your pardon
not Chris but uh representative months
have you worked out a timeline for this
um so I got this bill last night and I
did take a look at it um and and if you
don't mind I I would like to make a few
comments if that's okay yeah of course
not exactly well I mean it's not up to
me go ahead is that okay is it okay with
the chair
I'll be brief and succinct so not try
not to bore you to tears
um
and if I if anything's changed from when
I saw it it's inadvertent and I
apologize
um but so a couple of things
um sort of a a technical thing with
respect to this is that it talks about
provider of Last Resort service that is
a concept defined in Statute in Maine
that does not exist here I think we
would want to talk about basic service
here that's just technical right just
clean up but I note that at the outset
in Maine when we when we did this they
were we listed out the municipalities
and those were deemed deregulated
um and then the purpose of the hearing
in each municipality which is outlined
here was really just to let people know
that this is happening and and give them
an opportunity to ask questions and
speak with the office of the public
Advocate which is similar to your
consumer Advocate game as well as the
puc which is similar to your doe here
came and sort of were there to answer
people's questions and sort of provide
information it wasn't
um there was already a finding this was
already happening and that meeting was
just to let everybody know what's
happening the way it's set out in this
bill it's like there's a preliminary
finding and then it's sort of a little
bit unclear about what happens in
between or you know and and I caution
you against doing it that way only
because
when speaking at that meeting the DOE
and ourselves frankly can't represent
this is happening because there isn't a
final finding and it it just sort of
muddies the water I would also say and I
encourage you to to reach out to Maine
they will confirm this it might even be
confirmed in their their reports they
did two reports on the legislation they
were required to follow up as to how it
was going some meetings no one attended
I think are most heavily attended
meeting had maybe 10 people
um I just I just cautioned you they were
not particularly useful
um we we provided notice in the
newspaper we provided notice in our
bills and people just are not big on
attending meetings and particularly on
this issue so you know we're not we're
not necessarily terribly against that
but it's I'm not sure it was the most
valuable I certainly think providing
notice via the bills and providing
information to customers is important
I'm just not sure the public meeting so
I have to offer that so should this bill
also require the our consumer Advocate
to to attend these meetings I don't see
I I think that's fine I mean I think
that's a good thing I think the doe does
a very good job representing consumers
in the concerns of consumers so it's not
necessarily necessary the only slight
difference is here in New Hampshire the
consumer Advocate doesn't really have a
role in Telecom regulation as I
understand that and I would encourage
you Amanda is way more knows a little
more about that I would encourage you to
to confirm that with her but that's as I
understand it they don't really have a
role in Telecom regulation since your
deregulation bill so it's that would be
one reason that maybe it might not make
sense
I've got more questions I don't want to
monopolize but um just I'll throw this
one out quickly
um so there was you know the
notification it must be in a newspaper
newspapers are so quaint these days
a lot of towns don't have them how are
they in Maine are they requiring social
media anything like that at the time
that was all that was required um at the
time when was when was this 2012 2012
yeah so I mean and they were they were
going that way too I'm I'm not sure how
effective that was I think I think
definitely customer notices and bills I
think
um you know we would have no issue with
websites and social media I think
lifeline and that affordable
connectivity program I think we've
proven through all that we don't have a
great way of reaching anybody I mean we
try all these platforms and then still
people don't subscribe so
I I think we've gotten dispersed and
we've got our media so much different
now that there isn't a terrific way what
about a certified letter U.S mail
I mean that would be fine too we did
them as as just either Bill messages or
inserts in the belt but okay similar
I guess you know I I
you know as I said this was just random
thinking on my charts no absolutely
nothing's locked in stone here I guess
my thinking on the on creating kind of
like the preliminary approval and then
the meeting with the final approval was
that it would just it just provides kind
of a um an opportunity that you know if
something is missed
so if there's you know a pocket of
people that's that that
somehow get missed in the mapping that
would lose service would not have any
alternatives it's an opportunity for
those people to come forward
and present that information to the doe
before they made a final decision and
then theoretically that if that was a if
that was confirmed and the doe felt that
that was important enough
they could decide not to give the not
the issue the order that's kind of where
I was going with that now
I hear what you're saying about people
not coming to meetings I mean I get that
yeah so yeah and and I think in the
confines of current doe process
um to the extent that's publicized you
can get that because not only can they
come when they're if there was written
into the process of a hearing at the at
the commission they also typically can
file comments I think you can do that
for your
um so that they have an alternative
means they can't necessarily get
conquered or I can't make the meeting
but I can file comments and the
commission takes that or the DOA I'm
sorry I will get there one day the doe
will take that into consideration
yeah
did you have any in Maine where's did
you did you run into people that that
literally you know by when they lost
their their landline service that they
had no other options
um nobody truly lost their landline
service
um we have not proceeded with line
extensions we have not with a line
extension I should explain means like
somebody built a new development and
maybe we don't build into there things
like that
um the the concerns you hear repeatedly
um are with respect to
there there is an age of people that a
landline is a landline is a landline is
a landline and that's just all there is
to it so there is that contingent of
people and you do hear that and you tell
them there's multiple other options and
they only know a landline they'll only
ever trust the landline
um and to some extent that's just just
needs you know sort of a change this is
a secure technology it's fine it can
offer all the things you need it just
takes education but the biggest concerns
tend to be around devices you know the
life alerts that people worry that their
security alarms won't work and so there
was a lot of Education in Maine we had
people come in and speak about how these
there are alternatives and these devices
can work off other Technologies because
I think people just you know again a
tried and true landline they just
believe that is the way
um and if everybody felt that way and
everybody were using it we wouldn't be
here today the problem is that is is a
very a small population and keeping all
those wires going for for what is of in
some areas where there's plenty of
competition of very few people is where
the problem starts to come in right
that's the issue that's trying to be
solved
a quick question for you I'm sorry
um have you had problems have you had
problem with municipalities as far as I
know one of the towns that represent
Southampton I believe Consolidated cable
offers service to them but they there's
no cell service in the entire town
because they refuse any cell towers
anywhere in the area have you had any
issues with any municipalities that you
know of that have had run-ins with that
I have not I have never heard of a town
that would be the first one that has no
um cell service
municipalities frequently have
ordinances against small cells which are
are small wireless devices placed on
polls they're sort of a new movement to
stop with that but I've I've never heard
of because Towers
depending on geography it can be pretty
far away and serve the town so I have
not heard that but in that instance that
town would not qualify under here that's
sort of the balance we're trying to
achieve is like people have Alternatives
um because as as we see nearly everybody
has switched to a cellular device that's
where most of the 911 traffic is coming
from you know
so I have a question on that sure
I represent 20 unincorporated towns up
north
and I think we've talked about that
before
yes
and until in this bill you know if with
those with those uh 28 Incorporated
places yeah so um
most likely I don't think they would
qualify the only way they under the
statute that I truly believe
unincorporated Place qualifies is if the
state paid another provider to build to
all of that town and then in that
instance they have a state funded
alternative to us that is supposed to
build to everywhere so I feel like those
people would have an alternative would
not be left out in the cold they may not
have cell service but they have this
fiber provider that the state has paid
to bring to each person the uh this is
not aimed at unincorporated a really
rural areas those are those don't tend
to have a lot of competition those are
like we're still working to get them
their first broadband connection not
their third
right now we're paying our sheriffs can
you you just came back on you were going
for two years off the delegation but we
have them going around going into these
areas because people have been moving up
there in droves in these places so we're
basically having a sheriff is going in
for safety reasons to find out who's
where and where right there's been over
400 different it's crazy what's going on
up there so that's something that that's
why I was just asking that question yeah
no and and that's that's not unique we
have a ton of unincorporated places in
Maine too I'm very familiar with that
but but those are not again unless they
they're paying somebody to do that those
are not the places that are going to
qualify for this and not really the
places that this is aimed at it's it's
aimed at truly competitive areas with
lots of alternatives
would it be better would it be better if
we just structured the bill around and
specifically defined areas like in Maine
I know you they identified specific
towns I mean in you clearly have you you
know where you want to focus I mean
would it be better to just identify with
those towns and say this bill only
applies to that
um I think I think for the first part
absolutely I think the second part
um is is clearly defined as well so I
don't think you divine towns with that
but defining the fact that the state is
paying somebody to serve the entire town
and then not forcing another provider to
overbuild over that
public investment is really important
too so I think you could Define the
towns in the first section which sort of
takes away the ambiguity or concerns on
am I going to qualify based on the map
and then the second section which says
if the state pays you to build to every
person in the town you're covered as
well
and that either is or isn't right the
state either pays you to Bill to every
earlier you you mentioned that it took a
lot of Education to get people away from
landlines and things like that who was
responsible for that was it the
providers the municipalities doe all of
the above
um so in each of these towns
um we put together
um fact sheets I think the the puc
mostly put them together they took our
input they took input of the public
Advocates on those fact sheets and those
were put out in the towns they worked
with us we had to sort of get our
messaging to a customers approved by
them so they were comfortable with that
we were explaining at least as much as
you can and sort of messaging
um and then then on both the puc site
and the public Advocate site they had
links to sort of here's where you can
find who the alternative providers are
they produce a guide called a Weight
Watcher guide that has the prices of
alternative providers so it was mostly
done through the the state government
and and not to put a burden on the state
government
but they are better equipped to
adequately represent our competition
than we are that's why like it's the
burden on us isn't it's not that it's a
big deal it's just you know us talking
about the rights of our competitors is
sort of a weird thing right
so were these fact sheets mailed out to
customers um they were presented at the
public hearings and they were made
available online I don't believe they
so as you probably noticed I hadn't
thought about satellite phone right
before right I was thinking of satellite
internet that's right uh so one question
that just came up in my mind was all
right if I have a SAT phone and I call
9-1-1 what happens and I just Googled it
and you do get 9-1-1 service on a SAT
phone for your country but I don't know
what happens after that I don't know how
they routed to the right local people do
you do you know anything about that I I
don't not sitting right here I would be
largely guessing I'm sure it
triangulates similar to a cell phone but
it's not being my business I would
yeah uh going back to representative
munz's question about focusing on a
local municipality yeah a lot of the
municipalities are still growing out
right if you were asked to provide
service as the town is growing out you
would not be providing copper service
you would be providing Fiber service
that's right as a preference that's
right
that's right anything new we build we
would build this fiber I mean you want
to create a future-proof technology
that's offering best-in-class service
um you know the copper network was great
for for what it was but it's not meeting
the needs of consumers who want to
stream all their content want to do all
the things they're doing today yeah
okay good you know we were Heroes when
we introduced TSL now you know people
look at you and discuss it after
so you're you're you're
obviously one of the the largest
carriers if not the largest would be
affected by this they're the largest and
I'm not going to ask you to speak for
the for the others but do you have any
sense what their reaction would be to
saying picking specific
um towns and locations uh so I I I think
in the first run and we did this in
Maine I think and Teresa's Teresa's here
and she represents the small companies
um but I sit on a board with them so I
generally understand I think that they
um would not want to be their areas at
the outset probably would not want to be
included in a list of areas that were
were
um put forth in this bill they may
subsequently change their mind on that
but they get some Universal service
support mechanisms from the Feds that
are different than what we get because
they're small carriers that I think they
would be concerned might be impacted by
that
if thinking thinking back to the
carriers Last Resort idea yeah if if we
move away from the carrier of Last
Resort
in this case then effectively it goes
who else is who else is required is
obligated by a carrier Last Resort
obligation yeah there there is no
obligation for any other provider than
the incumbent providers in the state
with the exception of
um carriers that have taken rural
digital opportunity fund money they have
some voice obligations but those are in
sort of census blocks the census block
groups really in discrete areas so in in
large part there is no there is no other
carrier I mean that's that's that's
part of the problem is like we we have
to take on a burden that nobody else
does it made sense when we were the only
game in town now we're trying to compete
head to head with people who don't have
they can make decisions basically on
deployment based on you know what's best
for the business not on
125 year old obligation
along the same line of plot what happens
to the local telcos though who are still
operating on a copper basis
um are they are they forced to move to
fiber in their territories I think most
of the small local telcos that are not
Consolidated have a fair amount of fiber
I think most of them are are operating
on a lot of fiber today that's my
understanding I don't know them all 100
but I think I think that's what's going
on
um just a informational question so no
one is doing copper anymore right
no well copper still exists copper is
providing service but no I can't imagine
a company would make a proactive
decision to build that copper over fiber
it's it's the same cost
um on and you're again you're losing a
lot of functionality is it the same cost
yeah so so actually in some aspects
copper can be a little more expensive
because copper is valuable sure but yeah
like in a green field situation so
nothing exists if we were to if
Consolidated were to build out today it
would 100 do fiber because it's it's the
same or even less cost in most
situations the reason copper is still in
play is because it exists it's the
infrastructure yeah exactly
so can I can I come back to me my last
question so if we said if we said for
example that you know that this only
applies to Manchester Nashua Keen
Portsmouth you know whatever
and then also to the areas where the
state or the feds have provided you know
funding
that would presumably benefit you
but what about the small Telecom company
that's providing services in town X
um they would no longer they wouldn't
have the ability to be to petition for
relief from the obligation right that's
right that's right and that that could
be a detriment yeah absolutely I can't
believe that they'd be terribly excited
about that right and it could be a
detriment to us as as well because there
may be other areas that subsequently
become incredibly competitive so it's
it's maybe not ideal but as a first step
that makes sense or if you look at Maine
they sort of did you know first step
these municipalities and then you can
petition subsequently and they did a
rule making instead of a process for
hmm
Teresa Rosenberger Bernstein sure I
represent the New Hampshire telephone
Association which is Consolidated as
well as TDS Bretton Woods Dunbarton and
Granite State telephones so I have all
what the I call the Ma Bell Legacy
incumbent local exchange carriers what
the association likes about this bill is
the flexibility
and certainly if you decide to go and
put towns in I will speak to each member
before you do a final to see if they
wanted some towns towns included but the
way the bill was originally drafted was
to give flexibility so they could choose
whether they wanted to keep Universal
service or they wanted to give it up and
and go forward and so I don't know I I
know where they are right now I don't
know where they'll be in two years and
so that's why we drafted it with the
with the flexibility but I certainly
will go ask them if you decide to go and
do specific tips
so I'm just clarifying when you say that
you're supporting this bill do you mean
the amendment that is in front of us or
that well they have the original bill
they have not seen the amendment because
like Sarah I got it last night okay and
also household 2 came out last night
which
so I was up late reading and haven't
finished the whole thing yet yeah yeah
and and started at nine this morning
with Casa downstairs so yeah uh I'm
gonna send it to them as soon as I um as
I get back okay and but I thought since
I saw it late not late but last night
that I'd hear the conversation and since
you've got a couple of days to get back
to them and say this is kind of where
you're you're looking and what do you
think yeah so no um representative munz
um shared the original main bill with me
which does list the towns and and
municipalities is that too restrictive I
mean might there be a town that's not
listed that accidentally becomes
that should be on the list or something
well I think that that is problematic
because you may have a town that becomes
covered and would qualify that's
actually pretty expensive to maintain
versus another town that's on the list
that might not be as expensive to
maintain and I think the point is you
want to use your resources most wisely
because even though there's been what 90
million dollars given out for broadband
that still isn't covering the whole
state yeah and so you know we look at
when I ran fear point my goal was to
have the North Country I wouldn't talk
to Ray Burton have the North country
that last line uh that last mile served
and I failed or shall I say we all fail
but uh but I think it gives the company
a little more flexibility to say okay
there may be one of your unincorporated
places that really does need it so it
might make more sense to go petition for
this town versus that town but this
town's not under so it sounds like
you're you're advocating that we add
towns no I'm just advocating for
flexibility because I I think the the
Landscapes changing so much so that I
just what we may say today might not be
exactly yeah well that's what I'm that's
right
my clients and I would advocate for
flexibility okay thank you
the
yeah I'm not sure that I necessarily
believe that we should add towns I mean
I think the the the the the the
I guess the rationale for doing it is it
maybe limits it gives some comfort to it
gives people comfort that there aren't
going to be a lot there aren't going to
be this group of people that are going
to be without service because those
large towns we know in those large areas
they've got alternatives
it's it's
um
you know and and we just can go into
this feeling comfortable that there
isn't going to be you know somebody
stuck in a valley somewhere or Tom on
his Mountain that uh doesn't have
service so should we identify areas by
population or is that not you know if
it's if it's under a certain I don't
necessarily know what that does either
yeah okay just a thought I I would think
the network would be the best place to
look it's how you've distributed it what
are your outlying points where you you
kind of set limits that you're not going
to exceed anymore and you're going to
bring fiber in I would think that would
be kind of the way you'd want to look at
it that's that's probably what should be
mad
yeah the the problem with that is that
um you know it's not like there's copper
to hear and we want to bring fiber out
it's that the copper infrastructure is
aging the switching equipment is having
component part issues so we're
overlaying the network over it right so
it's like of course you know in conquer
is a great example we offer copper
service that that's up and running we've
built I think we're working on a
Merrimack Crossing but other than that
built the entire city uh with fiber
um an alternative service so you know
it's not a it's not like the end of the
line and then we're going out from there
it's we're really rebuilding the network
with the technology that's meeting the
um do you have uh just curiosity because
of the fiber overlay do you all have
mapping of where there's currently fiber
whether it's projected fiber in the near
future and weather is not fiber right
now to be projected so we do we do
um we
the the second part the the where it
exists today is relatively easy the
second part is where we get concerned uh
people ask us about that and and as a
company our plants change so we may have
something that we've been prepared to
build fiber and a competitor comes in
and builds it so we invest elsewhere or
you know we get out and we engineer it
and it's actually a little more
expensive than we planned so we don't go
as far into the town so we are very
hesitant to provide future future plans
because one we're telling our
competitors exactly where we're going
that creates an issue and two things can
change and then consumers are
disappointed so we we try to keep that
within the budget year
um as far as indicating where we're
actually going because if it's in a
budget year it definitely is going to
happen it's been budgeted if it's false
outside that it starts to get tricky
right
it sounds like the map that the state is
building is
going to be very similar if not
identical to the map that is already in
existence through the FCC that's sort of
my understanding so we had to file
yesterday so the only thing I will say
and and this is sort of minor and you're
always going to deal with this is that
it's always going to by its nature be
six months behind right because you have
to pick a point in time and you have to
map that and that takes some some effort
and so it's always sort of six months
behind so we're filing you know now for
um you know previous stuff I think
through September 30 or something like
that so it's always going to be a little
bit behind but you know six months is
not is not a killer here so I'm not
worried about the sort of it's lagging
and something's changed issue
um you know I think we'd all feel better
if we saw we saw the math but I presume
it to be very similar I am unaware of
work they're doing that will make it
much different from what the FCC is
doing I I've heard some concerns that
the map just isn't it that you know it
it leaves it leaves pockets of people
out yeah so a couple of things
um no no mapping is that is completely
accurate and if if you get to have the
joy that we get to do
um which is figuring out addresses and
what their geo coordinates are and
exactly what you know who's right like
if you go on Google Google or sometimes
you see it puts your house over here
your house is really over here right
there's just some inaccuracy
um that just is going to exist that you
can't get past
um you know I was talking to the woman
from MMA and she was concerned because
her address didn't show up well she in
subsequent conversations doesn't have
any lines to our house there is no 9-1-1
service currently at her house the the
underlying data is a 911 database so if
you can't today call 9-1-1 there's
nothing mapped out about calling 911 in
the future because you never had a line
a line built to your house for that and
you know that that is going to be that
is not going to get fixed in New
Hampshire like I it could get fixed in
New Hampshire I am curious to how what
database they would use to find places
that are off the grid for all intents
and purposes I don't know how they would
do that
um and I haven't heard a good answer to
how they're going to find those places
um I've heard some states use
crowdsourcing you know I exist I'm here
I think that's had some success um
limited again people people don't spend
a lot of time figuring out how to fix a
map unless they're really invested but
oh most most normal humans proceed on
without doing that so unfortunately
you're always going to deal with some
some amount of inaccuracy because it's
always based on the database and the
database is always going to be
to some extent not perfect
um I mentioned this before that that the
time line of this bill of this amendment
proposed amendment um which you know it
I I think it's pretty solid but um if
you add up all of the times it looks
like you it takes almost 12 months to go
from start to finish and that's
acceptable
um I I think the biggest hold on that
wasn't that really wasn't the intent the
intent was that it would be 180 days
yeah from from from the start of the
petition to when the order the final
order gets
it would be it would be 180 days from
the petition to the order and then I
guess the way I worded it there would be
a kind of a six-month transition period
where people would have the chance then
to pick another service I mean yeah
maybe it is maybe when you add
everything up and so it's 180 days but
but they're allowed to extend like an
additional third it's a year like I said
um I added them up
I mean
would we like everything to be shorter
yes would we like it to be easier yes is
six months an unreasonably long time in
a doe process no
um you know we whenever we get a time
crunch list less than six months I feel
like we're all always unhappy we just
finished a case
um that had a similar thing and I think
everyone would have wished at the end of
the day there was more time well so so
likewise
um if the process goes longer than these
these guidelines are there independent
penalties involved I mean well as I read
it and this is not uncommon it has a
outer limit the the doe shall issue in
order in six months
um and so I think that's a hard date for
them I think they have to meet that yeah
that's not uncommon in this industry
tariff approvals follow timelines that
have card dates
um if both parties want to change that
there's you know you can pull it and
refile I mean there's ways you can if
both parties agree but I think that's a
good sort of normal hard date so that
doesn't concern me and then the other
part is really on us you have to keep
the service going for six months to give
them a chance to get off I don't think
there would be a penalty for taking
longer I think you guys would be excited
if we even left it in a little longer
right like is that is that reasonable or
can it be could it be shorter I it could
be shorter I think I think six months
for customers is good
um you know that to me
is is you know we've been doing this 125
years six more months
now now maybe you know within the
process if something you know the
hurricane comes in yeah we would
probably petition for an exception that
says we're not going to go put back up
the copper for a month and a half
um that all fell down but that's sort of
an extreme case you know and I I feel
like the doe would see some
reasonableness in that
I have another question
oh no I'm not sorry actually I've got I
want to understand this so the the final
line doe shall Provide support and if
available funding to assist in that
effort
um and it says shall
yeah I I have it wasn't really mine to
have concerns because it's not me
um but I I did think that was sort of
probably maybe something that isn't
necessary in a competitive area there's
Alternatives so I don't know what they
would fund well that's that's where's
the funding coming from yeah yeah yeah
yeah and and that again was just you
know a weak attempt to try to you know
say that you know if people are going to
be at an economic disadvantage because
of this that they're we're going to do
everything we can to try to help them
out and I didn't know you know I didn't
know if the doe had any programs that
would assist with this I mean that's
really all I'm trying to do there I'm
not trying to
um
you know it's the bleeding heart liberal
in me so maybe it should be May instead
of shallow or something I mean there's
all these legal things but or explore
um yeah I mean yeah we could certainly
play around with the word but yeah it
was just a way to just say you know if
if somebody is going to lose their if
they're paying ten dollars a month and
that's all they can afford and all of a
sudden they're gonna have to pay 50 a
month hey right we're gonna do
everything we can to try to help them no
I think the intent of this is is
terrific I just think we need to to
punch punch it enough so that we see
what's behind it yeah so I was just
looking up you know again sat phones
um you know what what do they cost and
uh you can actually get an iridium plan
for as little as 65 a month
but that's for 10 minutes yeah which if
you're making a 9-1-1 call probably
yeah it that's an extreme that is a like
you're in the middle of nowhere you
can't get anything else most people
probably have a cell phone or a um Cable
phone that works
are they still those big monsters that's
my understanding
um because
it is it's not the low Earth orbiting
hmm
good morning and thank you for allowing
the opportunity to speak
um Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Catherine heck and
I represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and the 234 cities and towns
in New Hampshire
we had originally come to oppose this
legislation as we had some real concerns
about our underserved and unserved or
our last Mile and Middle mile Broadband
um members are cities and towns who
might appear to be served on FCC mapping
however we know that their residents in
fact do not have access to things like
Wireless
reliable Wireless at home or Broadband
we acknowledge that other states have
and are doing this the relief of carrier
Last Resort so we're not
um
unfamiliar with that this process is
taking place and new technologies are
coming forward and that's important we
we do continue to have many concerns
however and I heard some of the
discussions so perhaps I'll just start
touching on maybe the mapping the
granite mapping team that's being Head
Up by UNH but by your former Broadband
director here from the state Carol
Monroe so she has extensive knowledge in
broadband and it is in fact showing
high-speed access for both broadband and
wireless so just that was brought up
whether Wireless was included and that
is part of the plan so more than 30
providers for wireless and Broadband
will be providing data in addition to
several other ways that they can ping
individual locations to see if there's
access I'm not an expert in how they're
doing that I don't understand how the
Goblins in the sky necessarily work or
the elves but I will say that we have
been assured that this map will fact the
reason that they've spent the money to
contract for this map is so that we have
a more accurate understanding of our
middle and last mile underserved as I
was sitting in a public meeting I I I'm
not going to be able to tell you who I
can quote on this but it was a member of
a committee that said even in downtown
Concord there is only two bars sometimes
for wireless so and we're in downtown
Concord so the concern is that
without the accurate mapping and as
we're continuing to build out as you
just heard 50 million dollars was
awarded to the co-op a non-profit and on
February 22nd Consolidated
um CCI was awarded 40 million dollars to
do additional build out by governor and
Council from the American Rescue plan
act Capital project fund so we're moving
in the right direction getting this
build out getting our members served and
all the residents and businesses I we're
just not there yet last night I had the
opportunity to talk to the Southwest
Regional Planning Commission so that
served the Southwest bottom part of the
state out by where I live the
Peterborough area over to Keem and they
have some real concerns with this bill
as middle and last mile Broadband is
still a huge obstacle for digital equity
in that area of the state some towns
have done the public-private partnership
like my own to do that 100 build out
there were federal funds involved with
Consolidated and we do have 100 percent
in my community but in my school
district district for example during
covid we spent more than a hundred
thousand dollars getting hot spots for
other areas of communities where people
had absolutely no way to do homeschool
for example
um so that was really challenging and
some children had to go to the public
library because a hot spot wouldn't even
work in their location so we're still
dealing with these challenges from our
police Chiefs and fire and EMS Personnel
five percent of any population is too
many to be without an available 9-1-1
and I did hear about the education that
has to happen that again we agree the
technology does allow for all of the
same uses but we have members of our
population who like their landline they
believe in that and we don't want
municipalities having to take over that
educational role of trying to help them
navigate how in fact they're going to be
able to get these services
we feel like that's not quite our our
role although we do serve our members in
our residence and we do need them to
know that they will have 9-1-1 access if
they're in a a zone that otherwise isn't
available and then of course
affordability and accessibility continue
to be a concern as we know HughesNet is
very expensive if that's your
alternative a cell phone is much more
expensive than a landline so again
affordability for that potential three
to five percent of the population is a
concern for us as our local governments
sometimes have to take over helping make
those payments to individuals so that
they can have access and that is of
course a strain on local government and
we would like to avoid that if at all
possible so while we also got a copy of
the amendment last evening and thank you
very much for sharing that we feel like
this is moving in a better Direction by
using a mapping technology
that we know will be as accurate as
possible
but we still continue to be concerned
with the 95 percent in the middle and
last Mile and if that in fact
how many people will that impact and by
having towns named or cities I think
that would do the reassurances and while
I can appreciate
um the opposite side wanting the
flexibility we want the assurances that
this does not affect unincorporated
places or that corner of Keene because
of course telecommunications is done by
region not by Municipal borders so
there's going to be times when things
might not be you know you live on the
outskirts of your town but maybe you're
served really by
the town next door because again I don't
think that they and they can speak
better to this but they don't have
Geographic borders like municipalities
do there's not hard borders there and I
do know from the Southwest Regional
Planning Commission they said they have
a hundred people living in a square mile
over on that side of the state so of
course without density there's not a lot
of incentive for build out so as we wait
for either federal or state Partnerships
or federal funds and the public-private
Partnerships
we really do put people at risk and I
heard Keen mentioned and Keen has a
whole section of its of its City not
served so those are our concerns that by
defining a geographic border when we're
overlaying with
services that don't know Geographic
bounds our members are concerned so I
also would have to bring any Amendment
back and see how our members would feel
about it from emergency services to um
you know just in general to see what
their thoughts were and towns are
working very hard to get this Broadband
here I think it's coming and I'm not
saying that this is impossible and we
are willing to work on any possible
solution that we can come up with that
ensures residents and businesses have
the basic access to telephony we don't
create a larger divide and you know
we're shrinking the digital divide we're
not growing it prematurely
so I'm happy to take any questions that
um
so thank thanks
so it sounded like you might be amenable
to maybe as a first step just having to
build limited to specific
towns
well I think some of the lift that we
talked about between notifying people
Education and Training and assuring say
the Southwest part of the state or the
unincorporated places that there's not
going to be you know some process that
comes in and I can appreciate that maybe
people did not attend public hearings in
another state I can't speak to whether
or not that would be popular or an
unpopular decision here but just
ensuring that we know the areas and
locations that this might impact and we
can make informed decisions and have a
plan for how that would how that will
play out because as I stated if you're
saying HughesNet is your service and
T-Mobile
well I'm standing there on my T-Mobile
phone isn't working so it says it's
working but it's not and HughesNet is
like can be up to 164 a month as opposed
to a landline so we want to make sure
that there's an aspect of affordability
um and not a huge financial burden
because five percent of the population
depending on the size of the town could
potentially be a decent number of people
that are without an affordable reliable
option and again I think we're really
getting there with Consolidated now and
the on the co-op having 90 million
dollars and doing this build out we're
moving in this positive direction more
and more towns are creating
communication districts for example to
get that build out I think we are really
we're getting there but I think those
assurances are probably important to our
members to know who this would impact
and who it will not impact because
people are nervous about that
um
I have to say that's that's their
reaction is does it affect my community
now because the map is showing we're 100
serve but these are my options where I
live you know
um with regards to the education did I
hear you correctly that the
municipalities want no part of it
I'm not saying they want no part of it
but I think that becomes an unfunded
mandate who in the municipality would do
the training how would that work how
would we what you know what experts do
we have at the municipal level to teach
people what their options are as far as
you know this change in the law we're
always very careful not to want to add
things to local government do we want to
partner of course if there's public
hearings if there's you know
stakeholders of course Partnerships are
important but we don't want to be the
what becomes the middleman and many
times we would people are going to come
to our door saying have you seen this
what's happening to me and they're going
to come to the municipality for that
for guidance assistance that's who they
come to first so we want to make sure
that the education and training
materials that go out there are
comprehensive and it's not on the
municipality to help them find you know
individual Alternatives necessarily or
educate them um because we don't have an
expert to know that your security system
is hardwired into your phone line and
they're going to be able to do XYZ with
broad you know some Fiber we don't have
anybody with that skill set necessarily
right in every town but you're not
averse to sharing educational material
in town and City websites correct apps
no we've never adversed the sharing
material just not having to be the uh
not to develop point of contact or to
foreign
is that individuals are reluctant to
give up their copper line service and
and that's the hurdle we somehow have to
get over to be able to allow them the
digital digital world to enter their
lives and education is a piece of that
but I I I'm struggling to see how how to
move move ahead in that mapping would
just identify locations but people are
still going to be reluctant to make the
change
well and that's something that no one
can mandate any individual to write to
make that change and I do think there's
people with access to you know to Copper
that are choosing or for lack of you
know better understanding of what's
available to them they're not choosing
to move forward with digital and there's
some people that really don't have any
other access but to that their cell
phone up until two years ago my cell
phone did not work in my house
it did I had no cell service in my home
so what would my alternative be and I
had a satellite up until we got
Broadband um and that was 129 a month
plus tax and I had children so and
that's how I had television and Internet
up until we got Broadband so is that an
affordable
I'm not really sure I mean that's
up to each individual household so I
think there's a two-fold issue I think
some of its education and some of it's
making sure there's that access
um I live very remotely
um in a little tiny town in the
southwest part of the state outside of
Peterborough and there's many
communities like that and I think if
you're living in a bigger Community
you might not see that same
um
the dirt road with the 300 foot driveway
off of you know the third dirt road I
mean those are the people that we're
concerned with that deserve the same
9-1-1 and emergency service that every
other taxpayer pays for our main concern
is emergency service but of course if we
want housing if we want Business
Development if we want people to move to
our our communities when we need to have
more modern access and modern technology
and some of our communities are not
quite there yet
they're moving there though
we're getting there a
piece of this is is that we need to be
giving the department of edu energy some
some guidance as to how to think about
and evaluate this issue because
effectively they're going to be making
the the practically they're going to be
making the decision for us in in the
future and uh it's it seems to me we
need to give them some guidance
and I think I believe there's a member
of the Department of energy here and
they'd be best to speak to the agency
um they're certainly experts this is
their area and of course
we as you know Municipal Partners would
have no reason to believe that agency
would not make sure that every
Avenue has been explored and that
they're fully vetting any any change
that this might cause to municipalities
residents businesses to make sure it's
in the best interest of New Hampshire
citizens of course so how that piece of
the legislation works out I think you
are we
I guess you know I hear everything
you're saying and I think they're all
very legitimate concerns
um
in you know my I guess one of my
reactions to that as well maybe we just
need to wait we're not ready yet to move
in this Direction I mean is is that kind
of is that what you're saying or is it
or is there a way to just start
moving down the path that we need to be
moving down I think I think I would hope
that everybody agrees that it you know
we got to do something
so I think that's a challenging question
for me because I think we have two sides
to the coin here um we have where my
members who I represent my clients feel
that
um unless we until we can know the towns
the areas exactly identify that this
would impact we feel it's premature if
we could be provided with a list and be
assured by those communities that they
don't have people that will be left
without then I think we could have a
different conversation but we don't have
that information or data right now and
we don't want to be obstructionists we
do understand that technology and
progress have to move forward but we do
have to look out for the best interests
of our clients who actually represent
the same constituents and taxpayers you
know that that you all do so we want to
make sure that we're not leaving anybody
without so you're not getting the phone
call saying
you know I don't have any options
um we so we are willing to listen to any
type of solutions that we could come up
with and I think again that reassurance
that this is the areas that it will
impact these are the residents this is
the community I think that helps
everybody move forward in a different
way right now we're just hearing
anecdotally who it might impact we're
not seeing on on paper who it might
impact SO waiting until the map's
available and then and then seeing I
think revisiting the map is going to be
extremely helpful
um I believe and I believe that
again we continue to make great strides
I think the commissioner of Bea said
that we were they were hanging 20 miles
a week a day or a week of of fiber um up
by the co-op and of course Consolidated
just got that award they're going to be
you know they move very quickly in this
build out so I think it just really
depends on the amendment and and how um
or the bill itself and and how it you
just you all decide on the policy to
move forward
um whether or not we have to continue to
voice our concerns or potentially
opposition
um
um looking at this Devil's Advocate if
this was able to pass would this and
it's already moving fast already would
this not just help push everything
forward faster than what it has in the
last three times this bill's failed
um so I think I have mixed thoughts on
that because Senate Bill 222 was just
itl then the Senate which would have
allowed revenue bonds to be taken out
and there's a Communications District of
16 towns up north being in Carroll
County being created because they cannot
get anyone to come in for middle and
last mile of broadband and the state did
not identify them as the priority need
for some of these other grants right now
so that's an example where
we're still kind of in a Lurch you know
we have 16 towns that know they want to
do something they're trying to form
their Communications District to exhaust
every opportunity and they can't get any
individual provider or P3 public-private
partnership to work with them they've
tried for the last several years so to
say that'll help this move forward I
can't I can't speak to whether or not
that will be the case because of course
if I just came from Private Industry I'm
going to invest where there's density
and profit and this is a digital Equity
issue as well as a for us in emergency
services issue so I think
um
I think that's a double-edged sword
still right now to to we I don't have a
crystal ball to know whether or not
that'll that'll go through but we do
have 16 towns in Carroll County that
cannot
get anything moving forward with that
middle and last mile of broadband and
they're considered most some of them are
I don't know that this would
create the incentives to go there if
there's already companies that are not
willing to partner that are already
there
um just along those lines isn't
isn't something better than nothing
you know I mean it's it's clear that if
we wait until everything is in place and
and yeah it could be years it could be
years and these these people
I I don't know I mean I'm kind of along
the lines of you know
wouldn't wouldn't it be better to push
so gently but push so so I think we have
um shared that I think if there were the
towns and cities identified and we had
actual that actual data we could feel
more comfortable in going back to our
members but of course I am the voice of
234 and I can't I can't speak on their
behalf whether or not as the legislation
is currently written our members are not
comfortable
um moving forward I
that's you know my personal opinions
aside or anything else that's that's
what I am I'm here to advocate for and
here to support and we appreciate that
you're listening to our concerns and
again we acknowledge that other states
are doing this and have done this and
Technology's moving forward we're not
saying that nothing's impossible
um but the flexibility right now in the
legislation is a concern of ours
um
so yeah I'm just a little concerned that
maybe we're dragging our feet
um because we're just not comfortable
with the technology or something so I
mean we we've got to move forward at
some point you know and yeah and the
policies are certainly all you know yeah
but you also said you you have not
reviewed the amendment no I have I have
I have reviewed the amendment um and you
just haven't brought it back I I but we
got it last night so I I can't get it to
you know yeah our our members um quickly
enough um for the turnaround to say
whether or not they feel more
comfortable again I do know that if the
carrier of Last Resort could demonstrate
the locations in which they would like
to be relief from again I think those
are the types of
con
those are the types that's the type of
information our members have shared
would be tremendously helpful to having
them
um decide whether or not it
they can be more comfortable with this
type of legislation so representative
munz um I was the one that said to take
the towns out but it sounds like it's
okay well thank you so much for this
opportunity we really appreciate you
listening
I know that we talked about I mean I
heard the number 20 000 for population
bandied about like you know it sort of
applied to tens of over 20 000. so
um if we were to say use that as a cut
off that would be 13 towns and cities
good morning Amanda Noonan with the
Department of energy
um
I will start by saying I have not had an
opportunity to review this amendment
thoroughly or with anyone else at the
department so I can't comment
um on the content with other than what
I've heard this morning so I would just
offer that
um
I think representative Thomas you
flagged the line in the possible
Amendment of the department providing
support and funding we have no funding
available to provide any type of support
um
we would be challenged I think to
but challenge is perhaps not the right
word
uncomfortable providing an individual
resident of the state with a
recommendation about what service
provider they should choose for their
telecommunications service if they found
themselves in a situation where their
landline provider or their landline
service was going away for some reason
for the same reasons that were
uncomfortable telling residents in the
state whether they should choose a
competitive electric supplier for their
energy piece of their electric bill
and if so who they should pick were
hesitant or uncomfortable weighing in on
those choices that are very individual
and up to the customer in terms of
providing information about options that
are out there that would is something
that we could certainly do would require
some coordinated effort to to identify
and reach out to all the various
providers within the state that are
offering a basic service option whether
it's
uh
IP enabled
um
some other Wireless some other type of
service we could make that information
available but I I would want to stop at
that point and then we'll leave the
actual decision making
up to the customer wouldn't it be
helpful to have a list like that at the
doe I mean
could that be an unattended positive
consequence of this bill
I think it would be very helpful I think
it would be challenging because not all
providers are required to register in
state of New Hampshire as the
Telecommunications provider before they
start doing sir doing business in the
Ripple out effect of the deregulation
that happens 10 plus years ago if you're
a provider of
IP voice IP service you don't have to
register it's a voluntary registration
process so we would we would need to do
some Outreach ourselves in order to
figure out how to identify all these
individuals or all these companies
rather
not
unattainable but it would it would
require some work
um the other comment I would make is
as I said having not had the opportunity
to vet this throughout the agency I'm
not sure if there would be some sort of
fiscal impact on the department itself
through this whole process you don't
think that this changes it significantly
enough from the original bill that
there'd be you know if we hired a
consultant
those consultant costs are allocated to
the utility bringing the petition and so
they wouldn't have an impact but I would
just want the opportunity to kind of run
that through other folks's Minds before
do you do you haven't excuse me an
estimation of how many petitions would
would this would result in
I don't listening to the conversation
this morning it doesn't sound like there
would be many at least on the part of
Consolidated but I I really don't have a
sense
is a 180 day or six month window to
provide final approval is that
appropriate
I was thinking about that as the
conversation was going on this morning
and whether that would be adequate time
um
I don't know I think we would have to
discuss that internally and discuss
it's kind of a two-step process there's
the initial review where the department
quickly reading through would say this
looks like you've met the requirements
but you know go do this other piece and
then I think my final decision we may be
to talk about whether that's sufficient
time to follow this this whole thing
through
and should the the puc be involved in
um the puc has no jurisdiction or under
the current statutory
um
situation over this portion of
telecommunications service
and I think you heard earlier this
morning from Ms Davis that
the consumer Advocate has no role in
telecommunications proceedings before
the commission or involvement in
telecommunications services that was
part of the legislation that was passed
um in an earlier Bill I'm sorry I didn't
I just
in my own little world
um in an earlier Bill we heard about
some complaints that were essentially
lost at the POC and in process of being
transitioned to doe
um do you envision
sort of some of these petitions going to
Never Never Land
even I mean
I do do you know what I'm talking about
those the the bills where they
we were moving something from puc to doe
and and one of the utilities got up and
said that their complaint had been like
it was nine months and they hadn't heard
anything
that's why I'm well so we had her to
build something like that or in a
hearing that's why I'm wondering if we
should have penalties um attached to
some of these timelines either make them
realistic or or have some kind of
penalty
it's
sort of I'm I'm not ex I'm not exact
exactly asking your your for an answer
on this I'm just putting this out as as
a concern so if there are things that
were supposed to be transferred to the
department that the department hasn't
dealt with they seem to be very
interested in knowing what those are I'm
um that would fall in that category
uh
you know it's it's policy decision
whether you think there needs to be some
sort of consequence about what happens
if the department didn't make a
determination
I can offer as a perhaps a comparison of
the Public Utilities Commission has by
Statute 12 months to rule on a rate case
and if they don't make a ruling the
utility can put the rates into effect
without a an order from the commission
better way to look at some sort of
in in doing my homework last night that
I was looking through the rsas and
there's there's a section on Telephone
utilities service territories
basically it says if two or more
telephone utilities find that they
provide the same service in the same
area or that existing Maps create
overlapping service territories the
department of energy upon application by
one or both of the affected utilities
shall Define alter or establish service
territories and then they list six
criteria for the Department to consider
and then the the the the the statute
elaborates uh about the department of
Energy's authority to make that power
and and and to actually do it and I was
just wondering if if we added a carriers
of Last Resort obligations to that
section in that consideration would that
give you a mechanism to to deal with
these issues
I would need to take that question back
and have our general counsel take a look
at that and see what it might look like
but I'm happy to do that and send the
information back
yeah I was going to ask you
the amendment here and
obviously it looks like G could pretty
much be eliminated
which is what what I've been marking
here listening to everybody
um
how does I don't think it necessarily
needs to be eliminated I think it it I
mean they can provide a list without
making a suggestion yeah I mean the
people need to find out what's available
correct yeah yeah and G also puts the uh
you know makes it clear that the
utilities the telephone companies are
responsible for helping as well yeah
I just think that last sentence needs to
be removed we have a lot of symptoms
anyway the last half of the sentence
anyway they can provide support or
resources or something or list but no
funding
I was going to say I'm I'm for this I'm
actually for the sought to pass for the
amendment the only thing it was like the
last sentence of G and then I've been
debating on on D with the changing the
shell on the first instead of two of May
um but then again it's 180 days so
that's why I keep leaning back towards
yeah
and I still want um to flag the
newspaper I just think that's antiquated
it's unbelievable you know you say it's
Antiquated but
every I mean like I have a major project
of the North country and it's going to
be the final hearing on it it's all done
by newspaper yeah but some towns don't
have it like Merrimack doesn't have a
local newspaper anymore I mean so
Nicolas is pretty thin on them but it's
the only way we yeah it's still the way
it is you know that was brought up in
there was a bill filed in um Judiciary
when it was on Judiciary two last year I
had two committees and that that's it is
it's an evolving problem but we're not
to the electronic stage yet that's why I
got shot down well I mean I'm all for
putting it in a local newspaper but
maybe Also let's modernize and put it on
a website as well you know the utilities
are not utilities the provider's website
it is we heard the Judiciary link last
year about this
yeah I asked one of the lawyers if we
could put hyperlinks and bills and he's
like no no we can't do that I think it
is reasonable though to say that it
should be on the municipalities website
is
I mean I know I can't make a motion on
something that doesn't exist yet but I'm
I'm I'm for
ought to pass with a updated Amendment
if that makes sense what what about what
about you know the the um the way it's
structured now it basically has a
preliminary approval
and then a hearing public hearing
and then a final approval I mean are we
are we okay with that preliminary
approval or do we want to just you know
Skip that
that's that's what's in B and um
there seemed to be some concern that
I'm fine with it but
um
but without that 30 days is it going to
be extended
further than 30 days
the concern was that the 30 days didn't
give doe enough time if if we scrap the
preliminary
well no I wasn't saying if we scrap the
preliminary the preliminary gives them
30 days
and the way the way it's currently
written it says you told the telephone
company comes to the doe and says hey we
want to submit this petition
and then doe says okay you've met the
criteria that we've set fine we give you
preliminary approval and they'll do that
within 30 days
and then you have to but then they have
to have a public hearing
and then get to get the information from
the public hearing back to the doe and
then they would make a final decision
based on that and is there a template
for this petition like they they a
checklist they know they have to include
this and this and this and this or do
they they have to meet the criteria
that's laid out in in above which is the
you know it has to meet the 95 or 97
threshold or it's got to be in an area
where there's federal or state funding
that's been right but are we requiring
specific documents from them to prove
this that's I think up to the doe yeah
okay
well I'm just a little concerned how are
we going to require this if we don't
it's I I don't necessarily need an
answer right now I'm just it's a concern
well I think that's where you've got to
be careful we don't get too much into
the weeds well yeah that's true too the
the section that I referenced earlier
talks about service territories when
when there's a dispute that the doe has
a mechanism to go through and resolve it
the the RSA that you referenced earlier
yeah yeah okay a lot of that is built in
there so in the amendment we could
actually reference that yeah yeah that
would be good and are we going to put a
list of towns
well that that's what I'm struggling
with I mean it seems like
you know that
you don't think so
yeah it just seems to be that's the
thing that would give some comfort to
the municipal Association that you know
that
okay
the only way the only reason why I'm
against it is like you're saying we were
talking about providing a push it's been
three years three times this has failed
and that uh if we do towns then we're
gonna find those outskirts will just
stay out of it forever they'll just
continue on and continue on what have
been the objections to this in Prior
times
yeah you said it's been rejected three
um this the same bill has come up the
last three sessions and it's been it's
been two last session and it was uh It
Was Defeated and it was because of the
uh the lack of capability for the
smaller towns outside so for the same
but what are we doing to address that
concern we're not really doing anything
the only right so far the only thing
we've been doing is uh
basically been relying on the
telecommunications companies to move
further out we have ourselves haven't
done anything legislatively to change
time here I mean things have changed
like they were saying here I mean
it seems like 100 years ago what's
happened in this evolution of this whole
thing especially since covet I know up
in my area is in school but
this is really it's an evolving it's
evolving like I said and I do agree with
them a little bit of uh
flexibility in this is uh what they were
looking for so
I guess I was just thinking of something
not
probably not the way we should be doing
legislation but as I understand that the
map's supposed to be available by the
end of this month
and if this bill if we if we were the
bill this way and it gets passed and
then it has to go to the Senate well the
Senate then has an opportunity they will
have they will get a chance to see the
map
and then that could be where it could be
thank you for your intelligence
um the 374 reference to the service
territories just to be clear that's
really about the incumbent local
exchange carrier so Consolidated has
this territory and Granite State
telephone has this territory it it's
talking about telephone utilities those
are the only telephone utilities this
bill is really talking about all the
other providers of services that are
overlapping so I don't I don't think
that'll fix it it'll just it just the
only purpose of that statute is if us
and Granite State both think this road
is in our territory they're supposed to
resolve who actually owns it
so I I actually don't think it it helps
okay so representative munz you've got
some homework to do
yeah I'm happy to take another crack at
this and I can circulate it to everybody
and then before we send it to OLS
experience
we're the leap of faith that that
I make the motion ought to pass with
representative Monson updated amendment
okay I'll what I'll do if it's all right
with everybody I'll and I'll try to do
it today I'll
take what I've given you and I'll try to
incorporate what I thought I heard in
terms of the few changes we need to make
get it to everybody so we can take
everybody take a look at it and then
once we're okay with it I'll get it over
to OLS and tell them we need it on
Tuesday
okay
we have to uh
get to vote
yeah that was kind of glossed over
foreign
s yes representative Noel yes
representative Corman yes
representative Wendy Thomas there you go
yes
representative merner
representative Summers yes
okay
yep
ought to pass as amended
as probable Amendment we can't vote on
and I will try to get the number on the
amendment correct the number on the bill
correct
looks like our work here is done
yeah not even social media I would just
put um Municipal website but keep the
newspaper I'm fine with that it's just
I think we decided shell we decided to